at least 49 dead 53 injured hundreds of
lives changed forever and not for the
better but we know this story at what
point do we add this to our list of
proud American traditions I don't know I
hate to argue I hate rolling my eyes at
people that I respect
hey leaving a conversation only feeling
worse so I'll stay out of it but at
least 49 dead and 53 injured there are
too many dark days too many heavy hearts
too many bodies too many bodies and I
don't know i watch my brothers and
sisters fall I turn on the news I try to
understand but we fight and we argue and
nobody is to blame and everybody is to
blame machines are to blame healthcare
is to blame gods are to blame we are to
blame but we aren't doing any
we throw opinions like punches spilling
out of our mouths like blood with our
last breath but nobody listens nothing
changes
and it happens again and again and again
and again so tell me what do I do
do I sign or donate give my blood or my
tears and what is any of it doing what
are we doing I don't know this is not a
time for getting defensive or being
offended no you know what I am offended
I'm offended that our children are
growing up in a world afraid of going to
school or the movies or the club that
place is meant to help us grow as
individuals are being turned into
graveyards I am offended that this is
our new normal
there is nothing normal about this and
yet active shooter in Texas a family
murdered in New Mexico seven mothers
mourn in Chicago another child lost in
Maryland two more lives in Florida
another in New York neither in Louisiana
another in Arkansas and that was just
one day I am tired of talking tired of
praying tired of wet cheeks and raw eyes
I am tired
I'm tired do we love freely or restrict
freedom do we change our laws or
acknowledge our illnesses do we
crackdown or straighten up or maybe do
we do all of the above
because I don't know much but I know
I've had enough
you